today's video is brought to you by
athletic greens more about them in just
a bit
the winner is
and with those words
13 1964 at the 36th Academy Awards as he
walked to the podium to a raw
conservation to receive the Oscar for
best actor for his role as Homer Smith
in Lilies of the Field in the process
Sydney Poitier became the first black
actor to win an Academy Award for a
leading role but that was just a small
part of his impact on Hollywood poetier
showed everyone that it was not only
possible to Showcase people of color as
genuine characters instead of racist
caricatures but it was also profitable
audiences didn't shy away simply because
Poitier played an educated man who was
an equal to those around him quite the
opposite of factors they turned him into
one of the biggest box office draws of
the 60s party a was a Pioneer a role
model and an ambassador all rolled into
one and his influence on race relations
in America during the 20th century was
immeasurable
thank you
Sydney Poitier was born on February 20th
1927 the youngest of seven children to
Reginald Poitier and Evelyn Autumn his
parents were tomato Farmers from the
Bahamas back then still part of the
British Empire but Sydney was actually
born in Miami arriving two months
premature while his parents were on a
trip to Florida to sell their produce
from the very moment he was born Sidney
Poitier had to fight against the odds he
was a weak baby who weighed under three
pounds birth his parents had already
lost Offspring before unfortunately
infant mortalities were a far too common
occurrence on the remote Cat Island
where they lived Reginald Poitier sought
no future for his newborn son and had
already visited an Undertaker to prepare
for the inevitable Evelyn however was
not ready to give up on her child so she
insisted that they remain in the United
States to try and nurse their baby back
to health her maternal efforts paid off
and after three months of tender loving
care young Sydney was strong and healthy
and ready to go home as an added bonus
his Miami birth gave him American
citizenship which would prove useful
later wrong but for now it was back to
the Bahamas life on Cat Island was hard
to say the least but it was uniform
basically everyone was poor and the
locals relied on a barter economy about
as much as they did on Cold Hard Cash by
comparison to other Islanders you could
say the partyers were well off they had
their own horse and cart and even a
donkey and their fields were always rich
and fertile thanks to a nearby cave
filled with bat guano but at the same
time the entire family of nine lived in
a three-broomed stone heart and wore
shirts made out of empty flower sacks
for Sydney this didn't matter because he
didn't know a life other than this he
didn't know of large houses with
electricity and running water for him
once he was done with his chores the
entire Island became his playground he
would spend the rest of his day roaming
from one corner of the island to the
other fishing climbing trees swimming in
the ocean gathering fruit Ultra sitting
on the pier and watching the ships go by
back home Sydney indulged his artistic
side from an early age he was a
natural-born performer and he loved
using old clothes to create characters
for himself and act out scenarios in
front of the family Poitier considered
his childhood on Cat Island idyllic but
he later realized that this was only if
you were a child for the grown-ups who
were saddled with the burdens and
responsibilities of adulthood a life on
Cat Island was no picnic and it was made
eminently worse by the arrival of the
Great Depression in 1936 Florida
restricted tomato imports from the
Bahamas meaning that Reginald Poitier
lost his main Market just two years
later he concluded that life as a farmer
on Cat Island was no longer tenable he
decided to pack up and move the family
to the big city the Bahamian capital of
Nassau so let me introduce to you ag1 by
athletic greens it is the nutritional
Cornerstone for your health Journey It's
a combination of nine Health Products in
one simple scoop which replaces your
multivitamin multi-minerals pre and
probiotics immunity support and more
it's designed to make taking care of
your health much easier it is a daily
habit that I have I typically have it in
the morning take a scoop from there put
it in here shake it up with some water
and you are good good to go it takes I
don't know what a minute and then you
drink it and it tastes good
foreign
is made up of 75 high quality vitamins
and minerals they're listed all on the
back here and it's manufactured to the
strictest quality standards the
ingredients in ag1 sport whole body
Health impacting everything from sleep
and digestion to energy and mood to
immunity and more look my everyday
routine has changed because of ag1 like
I said with my coffee in the morning and
I just feel like it increases my energy
gives me that boost to continue my day
so click the link in the description
below for a one year supply of immune
sporting vitamin D3 as a bonus that's
upside down
and also five travel packs so you can
stay up to date with your ag1 on the go
and now back to today's video
foreign
Poitier left gas Island burst and she
brought Sydney along for the 11 year old
sailing into Nassau was like stepping
into a different dimension from afar he
thought he saw the road filled with
scurrying beetles only to realize once
he got closer they were cars He Saw
houses with electricity for the first
time and shops filled with all sorts of
wondrous inventions like cameras and
washing machines it was even the first
time that the young boy saw his face in
a mirror for Sydney it was a world
filled with new sights and experiences
but unfortunately not all of them were
pleasant for the first time ever he
became aware of the role that race
played in the modern world he wasn't a
small child anymore who need to be
sheltered from the harsh realities of
Life his parents his siblings and his
friends made Sydney wise to the idea
that he would face hardships insults
hatred and possibly even violence all
due to the color of his skin school was
an unbearable experience for Sydney it
was a boy who grew up with a high degree
of Freedom as soon as his chores were
finished he could spend the rest of the
day out and about traipsing through Cat
Island but now in Nassau he was expected
not only to sit still at a desk be quiet
but to actually pay attention how could
people put up with this Sydney lasted
just 18 months in school before he
tapped out which according to him was
enough time to learn to read a little
write a little and sing raw Britannia
after with the 13 year old Poitier
decided to quit school and get a job
working as a laborer even though he was
barely a teenager Poitier grew up before
his time in more ways than one
physically he had the body of an adult
he was six feet tall and all those days
of back-breaking Labor quickly helped
fill out his frame with muscles he also
developed an interesting girl Cindy got
his first girlfriend after arriving in
Nassau but then just a year and a half
later he lost his virginity to a
prostitute who gave him a Parting Gift
of the clap but the most troubling of
all was the teenagers descended to Petty
thievery Poitier stole everything that
wasn't nailed down food tools comic
books empty bottles even if it was
something he didn't want he could still
sell it and make some extra cash
unsurprisingly it didn't take long
before a 14 year old Poitier ear and his
first arrest and spent a night in jail
it'd be fair to say that Sydney's
circular friends wasn't exactly the best
influence on the young man first they
took him to prostitutes then they turned
him into a minor criminal but they all
had their good parts one day they took
Sydney to a place he'd never heard of
before something called a movie theater
party was afraid to admit that he didn't
know what a movie was so he just went
along with it and tried to play it cool
they saw a western and suffice to say
Sydney enjoyed the experience but he
ruined his bluff after the movie oh when
he went out to the back of the theater
thinking that the actors he just saw on
the screen would be coming out through
the stage door still riding their horses
even with the slight confusion Sydney's
first movie was a transformative episode
for him ever since he was a little boy
he liked acting he just didn't know what
acting was or that people could actually
do it for a living but now third on a
steady diet of Western's gangster films
and screwball comedies partier decided
that Hollywood was the only place for
him just one problem though California
was a long way from Nassau in fact for a
poor uneducated black man from the
Bahamas it might as well have been on
another Planet but every now and then
the fates show up and play their hands
that's what happened one afternoon when
Sydney's best friend yorex stole a
bicycle and took it for a joyride he was
caught and arrested him because juvenile
delinquency was on the rise the judge
decided to make an example out of him
and sentenced him to four years for
stealing a bike Reginald Poitier
couldn't stand the idea of his son
meeting a similar fate and decided that
Sydney needed to leave Nassau his eldest
son Cyril had managed to emigrate to
Miami illegally and later even obtained
citizenship by Marrying an American
woman but Sydney didn't need to do any
of that he already had American
citizenship thanks to his fortuitous
premature birth so in January 1943
Sydney Poitier said goodbye to his
mother his siblings and his friends as
his father walked into the pier put him
aboard a rundown old passenger ship
placed a few dollars in his hands and
waved him off as the now 15 year old
Sydney traveled alone to start a new
life in Miami
for party a America was hardly the land
of milk and honey life in the Bahamas
was tough and Nassau showed him for the
first time the injustices of racial
inequality but at least there he was
relatively safe he'd never been in
danger simply for being black but the
American South was an entirely different
kettle of fish oh while staying with his
brother Sydney found a job as a delivery
boy for a department store one day his
route took him to Miami Beach in a
neighborhood full of lavish Mansions
owned by Rich white people he got off
his bicycle grabbed the package walked
up to the house and rang the doorbell an
older white woman opened the door with
scorn and content in her eyes she
screamed at Sydney what the hell do you
think you're doing and demanded that he
used the servant entrance round the back
before slamming the door in his face for
partier this was simply confusing he
didn't even associate it with racism he
just wondered why he would waste time
doing that when he was already in front
of the main door so anyway just let the
package on the front doorstep got back
on his bicycle thinking another job well
done but two nights later Sydney was
returning home from the movies and
noticed that his entire neighborhood was
in complete darkness in a Widespread
Panic this brother's wife got out of the
house and dragged Sydney inside dropped
him on the floor and told him not to
make a sound what exactly prompted this
reaction while the white woman from the
rich neighborhood had called the
department store and told them what
partier had done she demanded his home
address which his boss said no qualms
about giving and then she informed the
Ku Klux Klan who were currently
patrolling Sydney's neighborhood looking
for the black teenager who dared to use
the front door of a white family's home
and the reason that the entire
neighborhood was dark was that
realistically the KKK would have taken
any black person who had the misfortune
of running into them while they were out
for blood that's how Poitier's time in
Miami started and it didn't get any
better he soon discovered that the
police not only approved of the kkk's
actions but were just as bad one night a
police car caught Sydney alone in a
white neighborhood hitchhiking after
dark they allowed him to leave but drove
behind him for 35 blocks at a slow pace
while hurling racial insults taunts and
whatever else they could think of at him
while at the same time warning partier
that if he ever turned his head back hey
which shoot him dead right there in the
street unsurprisingly partier hated
Miami and wanted to get away as fast as
possible during that summer Sydney found
a job in Georgia working at a mountain
resort near Atlanta after six weeks of
hard labor party saved up 39 it wasn't a
lot but it was enough to get in the hell
out of Florida for good he boarded a bus
destination Harlem New York City
upon arrival in New York City the 16
year old Poitier discovered that someone
had stolen the money in his suitcase
leaving him with just the three dollars
in his pocket it seemed that New York
wasn't going to go easy on him either
but for the moment Sydney was stunned by
all the new sights and sounds ranging
from The Glitz and glamor of Broadway to
the salaciousness and the dissolution of
adult theaters and gaming parlors that
littered the streets of the Big Apple
for a few months party ate drifted from
one drop to another dishwasher drugstore
clerk butcher's assistant Porter
longshoreman construction worker he
never made much money but each job
allowed him to experience a different
part of the city so he didn't mind too
much it was a different matter when
winter came along he had never
experienced her freezing winter before
and had been kicked out of his apartment
for not paying the rent in the past he
had spent plenty of nights sleeping
outside but that wasn't an option
anymore in a desperate move party
decided to join the Army lying about his
age that he could enlist autobasic
training he was assigned to the Veterans
Administration Hospital in Long Island
caring for injured soldiers what he only
lasted a year as he was ill-suit to the
discipline of army life he returned to
New York with enough money in his pocket
to find some place to live and resumed
his life of minimum wage jobs at first
he hoped to save enough money to return
to Nassau having grown completely
disillusioned with America but then he
saw an ad that gave him hope of pursuing
his lifelong dream it read actors wanted
by Little Theater group apply in person
at the American Negro theater
unfortunately partier's first audition
didn't exactly scream future Oscar
winner he could barely read he was tone
deaf and he still had a strong Bahamian
accent in fact he angered theater
founder Frederick O'Neill so much that
he grabbed Poitier by the arm and threw
him out the door and told him to become
a dishwasher which coincidentally was
exactly set in his job at the time
despite the harsh rejection patio
decided that this was a goal worth
fighting for so he didn't give up in
fact it spurred him on if he had been
rejected politely partier might have
packed up his bags and returned to the
Bahamas but spiked can be a powerful
motivator and now he wanted to succeed
as an actor just so that he could shove
it in Frederick O'Neill's face over the
following six months he embarked on an
ambitious journey of self-improvement in
education learning to read properly and
getting rid of his West Indian accent he
modeled his beach after plot radio
announces like Norman brokenshire while
an affable elderly Jewish waiter who
worked at the same restaurant as Sydney
helped him with his reading if this was
a then Poitier's six months of Education
would have been presented in a 30-second
training montage afterward he would have
wowed everybody with a second audition
and the entire audience would have
gotten out of their chairs and clapped
while Frederick O'Neill hung his head in
shame but well real life doesn't work
like that partio was only slightly
better the second time around he was
accepted into the drama school's
apprenticeship program not because he
was the second coming of stanislavsky
but because the school didn't have
enough male recruits some of his fellow
students included Future movie co-stars
such as Ozzie Davis Ruby D and Harry
Belafonte after the three-month program
was over partyer was asked to leave but
he begged for another semester offering
to work as the School Janitor during
that time the extra training served
Sydney well and his acting crops were
impressive enough to Garner Poitier's
first proper acting role in 1946 in an
all-black production of Life Estrada
followed closely by another part in Anna
La Casta a few more roles followed but
nothing to really turn people's heads
butier was just happy with the steady
work then one day in 1949 he was visited
a talent agency inquire about any
upcoming auditions and discovered the
20th Century Fox was holding screen desk
for Joseph mankowitz's film Noir no way
out what the hell not partier he gave it
a shot even though he had already been
cast in a play he didn't think he had a
chance of getting the part but the
director disagreed makowitz had found
his actor so he offered Poitier 10 times
what it was making on Broadway and
booked him a first-class ticket and a
luxury trained travel cross-country
after all this time Sidney Poitier was
finally heading to Hollywood
Poitier arrives in Los Angeles in late
1949 but he couldn't help but notice
that it was just more of the same black
people lived in isolation in the valley
and worked menial jobs while all the
Swanky neighborhoods and thriving
industries were reserved for white
people at the studio lot the only black
people he saw were either janitors or
kitchen workers even he despite having
the lead role received fourth billing
and the same salary as the supporting
actors but there were tiny baby steps of
progress Poitier came in at a time when
Hollywood slowly but surely began
casting black actors in movies that
weren't afraid to present the injustices
they faced in society they were given
serious and complex roles portraying
actual people instead of singing and
dancing caricatures or stereotypical
villains in no way out partier played a
doctor who was well mannered dressed in
nice suits and spoke with perfect
diction at the same time its character
highlighted a serious problem that the
black community faced but the black man
needed to be exceptional in order to
receive the same opportunities as his
mediocre white counterpart the movie was
well received and people took notice of
Sydney Ida new offers came in steadily
and he made another dozen movies during
the 1950s highlights included Cry the
Beloved Country which boitier filmed in
South Africa Blackboard Jungle which was
selected for preservation by the Library
of Congress and Edge of the city which
was praised by numerous organizations
including the NAACP for its message of
racial Brotherhood but Poitier's biggest
success at the decade oh was Stanley
Kramer's 1958 drama the defiant ones
opposite Tony Curtis the Roland Poitier
an Oscar nomination for lead actor a
first for any black performer as well as
a Golden Globe nomination he had even
more success in Europe walking away with
the bafta from the British Academy of
film and a silver bear from the Berlin
Film Festival by this point partier's
Talent had become undeniable and there
was no doubt that black or white he was
one of Hollywood's biggest Rising Stars
it was just a matter of time before his
efforts would be rewarded with the
greatest recognition that Hollywood
could bestow an Oscar and that moment
came in 1964. the previous year party
had starred in Lilies of the Field a
comedy drama where he played an
itinerant worker who helps a group of
nuns build a chapel the movie was here
turning five Academy nominations and
Sidney Poitier won best actor becoming
the first black performer to take home
the award for a leading role although a
quick shout out to Hattie McDaniel who
has the honor of being the first
performer of color to win an Oscar for
her supporting role in Gone With the
Wind Poitier's movie career peaked in
1967. he did three movies that year To
Sir with Love Guess who's coming to
dinner and In the Heat of the Night all
three were hits and they officially
turned Sidney Poitier into the biggest
box office draw of the year yet another
first for a black actor beating out the
likes of Paul Newman Julie Andrews and
Steve McQueen but even as Poitier's
acting career flourished he had already
set his sights on a new ambition
directing he stepped behind the camera
for the first time in 1972 for buck and
the preacher and then eight more times
during his lifetime also starring in
five of the movies that he made it's
fair to say that partier's directional
career had ups and downs on the one hand
he made Stir Crazy the Richard Pryor
Gene Wilder comedy which became the
first movie be from a black director to
grow over 100 million dollars on the
other hand he also made the abysmal flop
ghost dad starring Bill Cosby for
partier it was All Quiet on the acting
front during the 1980s as he entered
semi-retirement he took a 12-year Hiatus
from acting and re-emerged in the late
80s with a few forgettable Thrillers
this culminated in 1997's the Jackal
which ended up being the actor's last
appearance on the Silver Screen during
the 90s Poitier relied mostly on
television movies to flex his acting
muscles he was singled out for two
dramas where he portrayed Nelson Mandela
and Supreme Court Justice Thurgood
Marshall his last noteworthy role if we
may call it that was that of narrator of
his own autobiography the murder of a
man which won Poitier the Grammy for
Best spoken word or non-musical album in
2001. other than that Sydney party ape
seemed content with the Quiet life away
from the spotlight in his lifetime he
received an itoad from Queen Elizabeth
the presidential medal of freedom from
Barack Obama another honorary Oscar for
Lifetime Achievement and scores of other
honors trophies and awards he died on
January the 6th 2022 at the age of 90
before leaving behind an indelible
Legacy that forever changed not just
Hollywood but America